please welcome elizabeth and ethan
finkelstein
oh my gosh
i am such a fan i've been following you
guys since you guys launched your
account on instagram
and then it was no surprise to me
whatsoever that discovery plus came
calling and launched a giant television
show with you guys and it actually makes
perfect sense so you had a master's
degree in historical preservation right
i do i have a graduate degree in
historical preservation but i was a
child who grew up in an old house and i
knew when i was two years old that
they're magical ethan you know you were
in digital marketing right so i have to
say the history meets the new era seems
like the most potent combination it's
really a brilliant match yeah elizabeth
actually was creating all these blogs
and i was like okay
we got to make this thing like you know
national like we we want our own cheap
old house to be honest too and we were
on this epic hunt and we were in
brooklyn in new york city like looking
for this house and we finally kind of
have
gotten our sheep old house which you
know i'm happy to say but um people
can't afford houses now right now we are
in a crisis the average price of houses
in this country is 380 000
and here we are showing on our instagram
feed houses for under a hundred thousand
dollars that are awesome houses that
need you and need your love and i feel
like it's the kind of that kind of magic
coming together of the magic of old
houses plus the fact that people can't
afford them like actual houses that
makes this feed so like hits the nail
right on the head right now thank you
for putting that into the world and
making that a resource
that's so viable for so many people it's
magical and it's attainable right thank
you for saying that but i'm interested
to hear from you like what is it about
the feed that just
strikes you thank you for asking me a
question that's so nice um for me i just
i love design i do believe it can
enhance our lives in ways that are
scientifically marveling what i love
about you and your design drew i mean
your green room i just wanted to stay in
there forever it was so sweet and it was
and it pulled pieces from history and it
pulled it together and i felt like it's
a room i'd been in before it felt safe
and i think that when people look
through images of these cheap old houses
they're feeling a familiarity where they
felt comfortable in their grandmother's
kitchen they felt comfortable going to
thanksgiving at their you know aunt's
house that had that same sink and
there's something to that that i think
we need to pull back a little bit
on everything being new
it's better for the environment you can
reuse the items you know you're saving a
piece of history with the house these
are
these are not where the vips live this
is where every american lives and i
think that's very important now we've
got someone here in our audience and she
bought an older home and is looking for
advice please welcome michelle hi
michelle
[Applause]
michelle sanders i'm so excited um that
you're participating in this uh please
tell us about the new home you got yeah
so we're very excited we bought it in
2017
and um we saw a lot of potential with it
and we love reading and
one of the things that we wanted uh your
advice about is the space that we have
where you know maybe perhaps it could be
a library where we could all get
together and enjoy reading together as a
family well i'm very excited for
elizabeth and ethan
to
tell michelle what your tips are
when you see this space
first of all
props to you because this is
like totally a kind of house that we
would buy
it's beautiful um you know first of all
i would say when approaching any old
house
you've definitely got to fix the issues
i'm noticing in some of these pictures
that you've got potentially water issues
that affected the plaster and before you
start any design in an old house you
need to make sure that you're taking
care of that kind of thing so it doesn't
because it will come back to haunt you
later on
um
but then i would say
spend a lot of time immersing yourself
in the original intention of your home
so this house was built in the 1880s i
would say it's folk victorian style
which was sort of like the victorians
for the everyman right so i would say if
there's anything the victorians loved
it's wallpaper so i'm like you gotta
wallpaper this room now there is
wallpaper in that room
i don't know if it's salvageable it
looks like it's highly damaged but if
you were to do wallpaper now the
wallpaper we're showing in this
rendering is actually from the 1880s
and i'm showing it to you to show you
that not everything in a victorian house
was garish there were some things that
were more subdued and if you like a
crazy wallpaper as i do i would go for
it but you could also do something
that's a little more neutral but also
very era appropriate
like this that's beautiful
in terms of decor in this room not
everything in the room has to be from
1881.
you have to a little bit get in the
mindset of how people designed back then
they came to their house with family
heirlooms that they were putting in the
house that they brought with them things
weren't as easy to attain back then
things weren't as disposable so there
were guns there was going to be a mix of
eras even from the get-go and so what i
would do in the space
is bring in some items from different
eras
you know portraits on the wall old oil
portraits mix mid-century mix sort of
like early
early 20th century mix 1880s get it all
in there and it will feel like a space
that's come to life um i i love what
you've done that's pretty yeah
absolutely and i think you mentioned too
you wanted to have some books in there
michelle and you know collect those
books get some of these oil paintings
and you know do it over time like this
does not need to be the instagram page
where you flip the thing and you're like
oh it's all revealed and here it is and
here's my amazing thing and the last
thing that i do want to tell you is save
a bit of the history of this house
because you have that wallpaper that was
there in the before picture and you can
bring it into the new life of this house
and you can make the new story kind of
incorporate some of that um old history
by bringing it with you to the new
modern space yeah i heard when you moved
in a moving truck like
got on top of one of your sewer pipes
and burst it yes
i'm sorry you're
you're a saint for like getting through
that
that could not have been fun no it was
just i kind of drove up and the moving
truck had backed up instead of the
driveway just onto the grass and
yeah sank and crushed the sewer line and
so the moment we got in it was you know
watch it was like watching an episode of
the money pit i don't know if you
remember my favorite movie ever
and then the appliances went and then we
pulled the car but i was like oh there's
stuff glued to the floor so there are
lots of little surprises but you have to
laugh the comedy the money pit the
floors the walls like that's the stuff i
love and that's the stuff we all relate
to
life isn't a before and after it's a
during so thank you thank you michelle
for having me
and
elizabeth and ethan finkelstein i swear
you are just i'm i was so excited when i
heard you guys were coming on the show
so be sure to check out cheap old houses
streaming now on discovery plus and on
hdtv we'll be right back
[Music]